[Music]
in got played new hoe submitted by Pearl
world loves JK we look at you our world
a man stole a woman's car while on a
date and then used it to take her god
sister on a date instead this was a joke
it sounds like a joke that sounds like
very alpha behavior isn't it incest in
nature god sister they're not related
no he's gone get out the car
I like your car this takes place in
Memphis that's some [ __ ] girl the
only ten I see
in here ain't give [ __ ] like that I
can't even think of that
like that's some like I don't give a
[ __ ] I am the man kind of mentality like
I mean it's not dope I mean you know I'm
just I'm just mind blown that someone
can be that [ __ ] confident we've had
someone do that us oh they still some
[ __ ] from us and then they let us borrow
that stolen [ __ ] I guess but then I
think the element of dating involved too
that's just some next-level like top of
the line gorilla [ __ ] mmm he's like the
king of all gorillas he's like all
[ __ ] all the gorillas and I do
whatever I want I imagine it like
happening during the day - he's like oh
oh let's close your godsister cool I'm a
little bathroom real quick
maybe yeah yeah he leaves that just like
buggin goes and picks her up
when I picture was she was driving and
he goes I just [ __ ] pushes her off and
he gets in the car and then but I don't
know it just finds the god sister
somehow so strong I just
godsister somehow you went to go pick
her up that's what happened to that oh
she's even hotter than any [ __ ]
pauses are out the car and then that's
why when she was the god sister and and
the sister were at the same house right
and he was like the God says to open the
door he's like oh man this [ __ ] is bad
this is my date and she's like oh hey
actually I'm your date he's like oh all
right and then they go on the date then
he pushes her out turns back round goes
back to the house he's like honk honk
let's get it with her car with her cars
[ __ ] crazy dude yes Wow now is mine
with his own story Wow all right so this
guy's name is Kelton what an [ __ ]
that is exactly five eight I did not
think that was exactly why
picture-in-picture saved and I saw this
five eight I already immediately thought
of you Bart's gonna notice this [ __ ] you
know the buttons on people's you notice
the craziest randomness [ __ ] he's
exactly why are you trying to be all
seductive in his [ __ ] mug shot like
you just like his lips and then put the
picture I'm talking about the confidence
in this man dude like he said they'll
try to be sexy to the [ __ ] birds they
gonna seduce the photographer he knew
the story was gonna go viral as he was
like leaving a good with his mug shot
yeah for the future honey yeah so maybe
he's actually five seventy tippy-toe to
be 5/8 this is gonna be viral
Kelton took funny haircut you get two
little pom-poms on her head you gotta
face man so they've known each other
since high school
and apparently like one day you just hit
her up and it was like hey let me take
you on a date and she was like okay so
he shows up he doesn't have a car so he
was like oh can we take your car and
julik alright so they take her Volvo
then he tells her oh let's stop by a gas
station really quick I haven't seen a
Volvo in a minute man
yeah you know I used to get Volvo and
Volkswagen mixed up like a [ __ ]
- I just hear like in the middle of a
Walmart parking lot like [ __ ] they got
me again
I've gotta be [ __ ] MP Oh like Bob
always like a short name for Volkswagen
yeah it was like they called it tiresome
[ __ ] yeah I would be looking at yeah
there's so many of these Volkswagens my
friends like that's a Volvo and I was
like isn't that the same [ __ ] is 11 like
enough about the Volvo's tell me that's
11 I'm just waiting for it to go on
okay so then he goes to gas station she
gets out of the car goes inside buys in
the cigar and then by the time she comes
back out he's already gone well so he's
like hey let's go to the gas station can
you get me she talked me it's secure
yeah so he has been planning it that's
how [ __ ] boss he is like he asks a
girl out on a date she drives him she
buys the [ __ ] blunt yeah she was
probably in love with him in high school
for sure for sure and he and he takes
the car so then I'll mean her mom picked
her up and then together they use the
GPS to track her car motion and they
followed the car to a drive-in theater
they find that he's in that car with
faith God says wow so this was all
completely orchestrated in plan sounds
like God sister never noticed that was
her sister's car so yeah well like does
it say if the God says it was like
surprise like oh girl I didn't know this
was your car and this is your day like
or was what she liked yeah use my god
sister's car and pick me up you know
I don't know that sabotage story it
sounds like he said of the date first
with the godsister yeah let me hit up
this chick why knows in love with me oh
so he isn't a boss after all he was
[ __ ] manipulate he's a sneak because
if if you guarantee a [ __ ] to any guy
he will [ __ ] do anything he'll come
in crying but like [ __ ] why do you have
to steal that like the god sister's car
specifically you could have stolen
anybody's car I take it back man he's
not he's not that uh he's not the top
dog anymore he's just a mean man he's
just mean and a weasel I thought he was
immediately just based off of the fact
that you stole the car and took it to
another date I mean any five eight it's
the sisters
that's pretty boss daughter Stan of the
girls I can't even think of that
it's like almost like getting arrested
right and then you steal the police car
to go do another crime yeah that's
pretty gangster it is pretty boss so
what did they say what ended up
happening after they no I think the last
bit of the story here is that she
immediately called police and like he
was arrested on the spot but uh what
movie were they watching yeah give us
the important details I haven't seen
driving in forever they're all the
drive-ins that I see around here all
swap me yeah yeah there's mommy during
the day driving that night yeah there's
one in paramount that's still up you go
I've been recently like in the last five
years that's five years yeah a lot like
last couple years I went with you you
know don't ya just lay back made out a
them saying hey Lance oh yeah did you
get the second base what is that I'm
waiting for near second base is boots
base is kissing not anymore
no first base is touching no second base
is kissing
I think first base is kissing not for
like the old school terms right I've
never watched baseball is fondling third
base is maybe get a little finger in
there or some head and [ __ ]
oh maybe I think third home run is
[ __ ] home - yeah vaginal what did you
know intercourse that sounds discussed
the scientific term Jen for faces anal
there is no fourth base that is fourth
base boom
you know it's [ __ ] bench the bench
what's relevant follows this three
straight bow is when the girl says no
and you should have been [ __ ] off her
oh no that's a that's a strike that's a
strike
what does it call when it goes out of
bound that's a foul bell how about yeah
if I was just like when you when you try
to put it in but you miss it and you hit
her thigh instead yeah have you guys
ever done any scummy [ __ ] scummy [ __ ]
what do you think the fines Commission
like um you are gonna go on a blind date
but you have like another girl's back up
oh is that scummy I don't know I'm just
trying to think of an example on the
spot I remember my friend was gonna take
me to go hang out with this girl that I
met all my business back into a o L days
and when you don't really have pictures
and stuff like that those a gamble back
then yeah it was a gamble but what she
explained was like you know she was like
five three you know hundred pounds or
whatever
[ __ ] man when we pulled up she was not
that she was not she was like five eight
in like something else
uh-huh and then I was like let's go
let's go let's go and in the park in
like oh no I was like I don't know what
to do my guess I've done something
similar to that where it was also
somebody I was gonna meet from offline
and the picture was really cute and you
can't do yeah and then when we met up it
was it was not what I expected you know
and this was in Vegas years and years
and years ago and supposed to meet up
and we I met her and I saw in my house
ah yeah this is not this is not what I
what I thought there's gonna be and then
I was kind of like damn my boy just
texted me like he's having an emergency
oh good one yeah he's like really like I
think he's like his chick is like passed
out or drunk or some [ __ ] I was like I
gotta I gotta go help
I got I got a go I'm sorry and I just
have like goodbye as a balance yeah you
know what though I try to keep friends
like I never make it romantic
immediately because I really learned my
lesson like I don't start flirty you
just gotta establish that friendship cuz
she might have friends she knows she
might have friends and then it's like
you don't want to be too flirty unless
you start hanging out with them this is
this online dating mmm so like in person
it's different cuz you know immediately
like oh yeah the vibe oh you saw you
flirting right but then when you don't
really know and then you're just like
she might be [ __ ] nuts
mmm but who knows she might have you
know hot friends or whatever right
anyways so I kind of keep it that way
and then you kind of go from there I
gotcha
cuz you don't want to be that [ __ ]
that was like super flirty and then all
of a sudden you meet her friends and
you're flirting with her friends and
she's I want to coast anybody for no
reason I got you I don't do that [ __ ] we
don't do this I respect women
it's 2018 so that's how you play you you
gotta take a slow be friends and then
next week you go for that [ __ ] sex if
you want to yeah sure
one week at least or just match that
night there the scubs though they kept
this you guys
[Music]